a Syrian or Russian warplane is believed
to be behind this
air attack close to a Turkish military
convoy it was making its way through the
opposition controlled province of Idlib
Turkey says it was heading to one of its
observation posts that in the Hama town
of morroc and like the rebel controlled
town of handshake owned a few kilometers
away it could soon come under siege and
Syrian government forces and their
allies advanced the Syrian Foreign
Ministry is accusing Turkey of trying to
stop the Army's advance and providing
support to what it calls terrorist
groups Turkey's local allies the
so-called Syrian National Army were
recently seen heading to the front lines
to help fight the government's military
push the National Army were sent in
massive reinforcements to the frontlines
in a blip and the second we have seen
today morning that the Turkish armies
and massive convoy to Han shizhong in
order to establish to base their and
prevent the Isetta regime from cutting
the m5 highway that highway will allow
the Syrian government to connect cities
under its control and revive trade but
main population centers like han cheng
hoon lie along the road the town used to
shelter up to 100,000 Syrians before the
military escalation started in April
many of them had been displaced from
nearby Hama province it's now empty as
government troops and their allies are a
few kilometers from reaching its centre
Syrian regime did not enter handshake
wound and fighting continues in the
vicinity of the city the Turks have sent
reinforcements to prevent the Syrian
regime from entering khan shaykhun and
as usual the Syrian regime targeted the
Turkish convoy Turkey is a key guarantor
in this region as part of the
de-escalation agreements and we do not
expect it to give up the airstrike may
have been a message from Syria to Turkey
whose Defense Ministry has condemned it
as a violation of existing agreements
and cooperation with Russia and turkeys
deployment of troops seems to have been
its own
message to Syria and its backer Russia
not to advance any further but many are
asking are both sides just posturing or
will this sharp escalation in tension
turn the proxy battle enid Lib into a
different kind of war senator al jazeera
Beirut